amuseur type que l'on peut voir sur les
grandes scènes et à la fiche des
cabarets jacques beaudoin a assemblé
dans la célèbre table de multiplication
une assez jolie brochette de cancre au
spectaculaire savez c'est une histoire
qui est arrivée à un inspecteur qui fait
la tournée des écoles de la région
parisienne et avant d'interroger les
enfants et se tourne vers l'instituteur
du gauche la structure que les deux
programmes de l'ataf aujourd'hui wesh du
monsieur l'inspecteur jolie l'intention
d'être rhji joyeux bambins sous la cape
de multiplication de ceux qui donnent
selon des études la table de
multiplication la liste des départements
avec les préfectures et sous préfectures
ne sont elles pas en effet les plus
beaux fleurons de notre enseignement
primaire
nous écoutons et déchets parfait elle
freine obtient un vrai tabou c'est chaud
par le punch effecteur oui monsieur mois
les formalités dépôts droit à 10 l
époque du but est de prague lille c'est
le facilita et de toute cette attention
cette offre est le fun dit lui téléphone
en virtuose à pagani lise l'arithmétique
selon lui c'est épatant j'y croirai pas
moi je ne l'ait pas entendu comme ça
depuis 1938 à voir les grèves
enfin les autres essayer ou gilbert
thiel puivertaine je me dis que son
parrain 3 l et tant pis c'est l'orgie
chez le ch est ce qu'un pur jeu et
buteur
c'est comme si vous l'aviez c'est parti
mon kiki
trois fois raquette c'est tout récent je
ne savais pas non plus alors voyez que
ça vient de sortir une surprise pour
tout le monde et part seul au catalogue
au point que pour prendre part mais là
parce que je les vois plein de retenue
cette la rue jeu cesa tout augmente trop
frais doit nous passons rapidement 3 x
games ont insisté et nous arrivons déjà
pour fait 5-3 autant j'étais brillant
jusqu'à présent par autant à partir de
trois points c'est mal et se voyait en
fait c'est que ça a l'air de rien vous
partez confiant la fleur au fusil tous à
berlin paie mon mieux ça risque d'aller
vous cherchez dans le savoir enfin c'est
mon avis faudrait voir la nasa doit
graviter dans les bières plus mais pas
moins voyez maintenant si je voulais a
cédé trophée teink combien je pourrais
le faire je veux pas vous assaisonnez
non plus au mieux au client comme jours
et je peux vous faire une pâquerette je
ne manquerai pas de 14 50
aurait du mal à refaire plus justin
c'est mon prix oui bah ça je viens c'est
bien s'il vous arrive de carnage
d'ailleurs je voudrais bien sûr j'ai un
peu les bancs du fonds est effectivement
un inspecteur venait d'apercevoir ou
pense d'ultimes de la classe est juste à
côté du chauffage central
c'est là qu'il s'épanouisse un de ces
cancres ils font la gloire de la
création française du comment vous
appelez-vous c'est à quel sujet il lui
en ai je m'en avait l'air
particulièrement doué voulez vous nous
dire je vous prie la table de
multiplication par 7
ma mère ne pas demander la table des
matières j'ai voté lol vous y tenez vous
ça il faut être vicieux pour aimer ça
moi je suis très au courant je suis seul
à ces prêts vous avez pensé une amie
laissé tomber
intéressant c'est monotone c'est
toujours pareil c'est des questions
n'est pas la table de multiplication par
j'en ai marre c'était
toujours debout re tableau ça me fout
les maris des gens dans les faits si
vous le voyez vous diriez a kiss et ses
guiboles minable que sont le pas la cob
de bohain savarona ohlala mais c'est
kivu mordret soupe au lait 1
vous serez content quand vous aurez un
cactus dans le myocarde
alors ne poussez pas il y en aura pour
tout le monde les femmes et les enfants
d'abord toujours dans les naufrages et
celui-là son air si j'aurais su vous
parle de vous si j'aurais su que ses
soutiens parleur est ce que j'étais dieu
on va vous n'avez peut-être pas levés
grâce faut pas discuter mais enfin
qu'est ce que vous travaillez comme
carafe au moins ils ont des chapeaux
oblige la bretagne ça vous passera avant
que ça me reprenne ses motifs
bon on va pas tarder à y aller
en tout cas je vous ai près nous
viendrait pas chialer après vous savez
ce qui vous attend si tu as la loyale
les yeux dans les yeux
rendez-vous au 15 20 vous l'aimez bon eh
bien nous allons commencer immédiatement
le compte à rebours c'est vous dire que
nous n'allons pas tarder et met sur
orbite n'a sauf bon chèque a320 lâche et
howie son parti peut-être temps à te
mets ton est moins qu'il est une maison
où étaient les têtes son âge il est
moins bon
c'était le tour est joué
cette fois ça me rappelle sam salam
salut j'ai mal écrit rocher
[Musique]
et voilà voyez vous même vous savez plus
mal et on ne trouvera pas alors faut-il
vous l'enveloppé aussi c'est pour
conserver tout de suite au bout de mon
jeune ami je regrette moi aussi on va
pas faire mal et c'est en ça commence à
être un peu laborieux votre machin moi
je pense qu'il ya à faire non plus alors
alors alors alors fouette les annales un
grand garçon comme vous on est craint
légion d'honneur une athérosclérose pas
que ça fait un peu j'ai encore un
problème sur le robinet à marseillan et
qui c'est qui va seul clokey le robinet
qui perd le bassin qui free il ya des
jours où ça s'évapore aimerions qu'un
115 cepandant l'annuaire faut le savoir
alors écran et berthe écrasé si je vous
dis c'est la donne pour me faire
confiance et la table pisé meurt c'est
vrai c'est toujours pareil je pense
qu'il passe le milieu de sa femme la
musique je me la rappelle au poil mais
ces [ __ ] de parole je peux pas c'est
plus fort que moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]